Volkswagens crafter was crafted entirely
by VW unlike his predecessor which was
developed and built in close cooperation
with mercedes-benz the new crafter is
purely Volkswagen and it's versatile the
crafter is available as a panel van or
with a loading bed it comes and various
Heights and lengths and with front rear
or all-wheel drive that phone for motion
VW's bad cause explains the advantage
for motion gives the crafters of course
mainly on ordinary roads it's sturdier
and safer especially during the winter
and fall when street conditions are
compromised also lets us do what we're
doing now driving off the paved roads we
have more stability and get ahead better
one colophon the four basic models are
panel van
minibus double and chassis cab all in
three different heights and lengths
the cargo space can reach up to two
point 19 metres high and four point 85
metres long for a maximum volume of 18
cubic meters 40 as an example Baron has
stood this wooden box snugly he put in
our euro pallet at the front wall of the
cargo space then he lifted the box in
with a forklift it's fairly lightweight
only 40 kilograms off the opposite Sonia
he lashed the Box down and fastened it
with a strap then placed two rods in the
front and back to make sure it stays in
place that makes emergency braking and
swerving possible and the load is
secured so it won't get damaged Citi
Field the crafter is not one single
vehicle but an entire family there are
69 versions available in total VW
designed the cockpit to be practical and
pleasant the steering wheel handles like
a passenger's car and VW has upgraded
the crafters electronic and assistant
systems
[Music]
new features include electromechanical
power steering obstacle monitoring
system and a trailer assist
[Music]
Dallas's trailer assist makes reversing
a lot easier even for drivers
inexperienced with trailers especially
when reversing straight back
it's an assistance system meaning it's
not autonomous it doesn't steer itself
but it does make things much simpler
you basically steer with this joystick
the way you'd ordinarily adjust the
mirrors the driver determines the
direction and the vehicle does the rest
the electronics work much quicker so it
requires a lot less steering when
reversing straight back and the
mechanics take over and guide the
vehicle in the right direction now the
trailers actually pulling the van
backwards for loading even heavier cargo
the crafters rear axle can now be
equipped with dual wheels
his purpose is simply to make the axle
shorter so the vehicle can carry heavier
loads making it more efficient as a
simple comparison is a short broom stick
is harder to break than a long one so a
short axle can withstand more pressure
old socks this llama taught him via the
dust under no matter how tough the
working conditions are the new crafter
is versatile enough for almost any
operation
[Music]